vale parlé avec une résidente de
terre-neuve à saint jean pour savoir
comment ça se passe pour elle s'appelle
jacinthe tremblay bonjour madame
tremblay bonjour je suis content de vous
parler parce que je vous entendu en
entrevue vendredi
vous disiez déjà que vous manquiez
d'électricité de votre côté comment ça
se passe aujourd'hui le calme avant
l'autre ben oui la bombe j'y manqué très
peu d'électricité deux fois mais pas
assez pour que des impacts dramatique
par contre il ya des gens qui sont sans
électricité depuis vendredi c'est des
gens qui entrent tous les gens qui
vivent abdelhalim qui est une île à peu
près à digne de saint jean sont sans
électricité et le vent est tellement
fort que les bateaux peuvent pas se
rendre
donc il ya des gens qui sont vraiment
situation critique c'est pas mon cas je
suis une situation critique la êtes vous
en contact vous avec certaines de ces
personnes là ce que c'est des situations
vraiment inquiétante
ben je pense que c'est difficile
actuellement de prendre la mesure des
impacts parce que on est en état
d'urgence est ce que ça veut dire c'est
que on on peut sortir mais on peut aller
tout près de chez nous j'ai pris des
photos que je vous ai pas fait parvenir
ces des photos que j'ai pris sur ma rue
parce que on n'a pas le droit d'aller
n'émet que c'est dangereux hier soir
j'allais faire un tour sur une rue
principale qui était d'énergie j'ai
rencontré des politiques invitait les
piétons à retourner à la maison
c'est trop dangereux à ce moment là on
sait qu'il ya eu des vents très très
importante comme si c'était un ouragan
de catégorie 2 qui déferlaient sur la
province
est ce que vous savez s'il ya des dégâts
majeurs où on n'est pas encore en mesure
d'évaluer certainement pas moi que je
suis incapable de les réduire
je sais que j'ai vu des photos il ya un
an
un groupe facebook a été créé je pense
la première journée de la tempête où il
ya maintenant plus de 70000 personnes
qui envoient des informations ça
s'appelle et nelson 2020 une information
center
c'est en anglais mais si des gens
veulent avoir des exemples de dégâts de
dommages et d'humour et un excellent
endroit
oui on a vu que les terre-neuviens
garder sourire malgré tout la dans
différentes vidéos assez humoristique on
voit circuler dans les médias sociaux
mais ça ne cache pas quand même là des
besoins criants qui peut y avoir sur
planche bien sûr là c'est vraiment toute
une tempête historique en tout cas pour
votre province peut-être même à
l'échelle canadienne
elle nous disait le pas parole
d'environnement canada hier alors qu'on
voit vos photos en ont actuellement
madame tremblay c'est des photos que
j'ai pris comme je vous disais autour de
ma mère enfant qui est l'endroit où on
peut alléger puis certaines photos à
raquettes parce que c'était dangereux de
marcher la neige certains endroits et
existe à côté il va avoir de la neige
folle où on peut vraiment aller jusqu'à
la taille
et là ça devient un problème et c'est
une des raisons pour laquelle on demande
aux gens de rester chez eux
oui et que les écoles sont fermées aussi
demain le son le si on n'a pas besoin de
se soucier de toute façon juste de s'y
rendre
c'est ce serait impossible et d'entrer
également dans les écoles on peut
imaginer que la neige c'est pas mal a
cumulé autour des édifices aussi
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que l'armée
arrive en renfort de moyens pour dégager
les entrées pour les hôpitaux pour les
hôpitaux et j'ai vu il ya sûrement eu
encore beaucoup de gestes d'entre aide
les gens que j'avais photographié en
raquettes pour l'émission précédente
je les ai croisés hier un quart en
raquettes avec des pelles il cherchait
des gens à aider parce qu'il ya des gens
qui pouvaient pas sortir parce que les
portes
la neige était jusqu au milieu des
portes de sortie tôt pour pouvoir aller
d'abord il fallait pelleter à cause des
rafales
la neige est très tard des blocs de
briques
on essaie d envie oui on sait quel point
c'est important d'avoir des sorties de
secours ans il peut arriver n'importe
quoi là dans la résidence il faut
absolument pouvoir dégager et je sais
que c'est extrêmement difficile de
comparer moyen de la vallée de la
matapédia je suis que c'est des grosses
tempêtes de neige j'étais à montréal
quand il ya eu le verglas
oui c'est vraiment difficile de devoir
les impacts et c'est un peu aussi comme
c'est un mélange d'innovation de neige
et du ragga donc la pleine mesure de ce
qui se passe on va le voir dans les
prochaines dans les prochains jours et
même dans les prochaines semaines madame
tremblay justement là et en terminant là
dessus c'est quoi le le moral
actuellement votre moral mais aussi des
gens qui vous parlez est ce que c'est de
prendre la situation comme et l'est où
il ya un sentiment quand même des
quiétudes ne pas savoir exactement les
conséquences réelles mais en fait le
moral je pense que si cette situation là
se passe ailleurs qu'à terre-neuve ce
serait beaucoup plus dramatique les gens
ici ont appris depuis très longtemps ne
pas se battre contre la nature mais à
vivre avec la nature
ce qui inquiète les gens c'est la perte
de 2 de l'électricité prolongé c'est
déjà arrivé dans d'autres circonstances
ce qui s'en vient il ya de la pluie
ça veut dire de la glace le réseau
électrique est très précaire et aussi là
où il commence avant je voudrais plus de
pension c'est le fait que les commerces
sont fermés les commerces d'alimentation
entre autres donc les gens vont
commencer à manquer de nourriture
tu vas y ait une intervention rapide est
là pour avoir des denrées pour pouvoir
revivre bien sûr et pouvoir déneiger
également pour voir l'ampleur des dégâts
puis on rappelle aussi en terminant
madame tremblay laquelle toujours ce
jeune homme de 26 ans qui manquent à
l'appel qui est sortie pendant le
blizzard on a effectué quelques
recherches mais dans l'assiette actuelle
c'est extrêmement difficile
on ne comprend vraiment inquiétant aussi
pour la famille moi j'ai vu des autos
des véhicules a fait ou complètement
enseveli dans le voisinage chez moi oh
la la il ya eu une avalanche dans un
quartier qui s'appelle de batteries
quitte à l'entrée du port donc j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup de gens le font des
appels au calme les gens s'entraident et
les gens ont beaucoup d'humour donc qui
fait que la situation est pas un fait
qui est très difficile les gens là
vivent avec sérénité et y sommes mais
l'inquiétude plus la situation va
continuer lui la quiétude de ce
manifeste de neige qui sont attendus au
cours des prochaines heures haman
tremblay je vous remercie de nous avons
parlé ce matin vos témoignages est très
important pour qu'on prenne la mesure de
ce qui se passe puisque on comprend
c'est qu'on est capable de le mesurer
seulement une partie actuellement des
conséquences mais je le rappelle quand
même un point de presse des autorités
très important ce matin dès 9 heures on
va suivre en direct sur les ongles du
crd merci beaucoup merci madame tremblay
merci au revoir